Ustedes han conseguido instaurar un
festival que se ha convertido en un foro
importante para el periodismo de la
región que desafíos tenemos los
comunicadores iberoamericanos en estos
momentos
Bueno yo creo que hoy hemos tenido un
encuentro sobre sobre libertad de
expresión y yo creo que uno de los
desafíos principales son los
amedrentamientos a periodistas que
desgraciadamente
siguen tomándose vidas como pasión
Colombia esta misma semana con el
asesinato de un periodista en el
departamento de Córdoba pero aparte de
ese gran problema instaurado en América
Latina
creo que el periodismo no es solamente
un problema en América Latina sino que
está el reto de cómo conectar con
audiencias y transmitir la información
cada vez a más gente de manera veraz no
entonces ante eso está el desarrollo
tecnológico está todo lo que se puede
hacer pero es el elemento Central es la
ética
quiero profundizar acerca de lo que nos
comentaba al comienzo ese panorama que
tenemos los periodistas para hacer
periodismo aquí en América Latina que es
prácticamente una profesión de riesgo
usted hablaba del caso de Colombia del
caso que vimos esta semana pero por
ejemplo en México también es uno de los
países con más periodistas asesinados
ejerciendo su profesión Cuál es el
panorama que tenemos en esos momentos
Bueno yo creo que el panorama siempre
desde la fundación y desde el festival
se trata de buscar de alguna forma una
idea de esperanza y una idea de
resistencia Entonces yo creo que ante
todas estas persecuciones y
amedrentamientos lo que hay es un
periodismo vivo que se adapta que busca
nuevas formas de contar que busca formas
de sobreponerse a esta situación Y creo
que eso ha generado el crecimiento de
muchísimas iniciativas periodísticas en
el festival se estarán presentando 16
medios nativos digitales que hacen parte
de un estudio que ha realizado la
fundación Gabo en el que se han
identificado 1500 medios en toda la
región Y eso es fruto un poco de la
resistencia y de la creatividad que
tiene el periodismo y de la de la vida
que tiene el periodismo en América
latitud vamos a hablar de otro asunto
que ustedes abordan también en la
programación de la edición de este año
el festival celebra en esta edición los
40 años del premio Nobel de literatura
para Gabriel García Márquez qué
incidencia tuvo este premio en la
literatura no solamente América Latina
sino una literatura mundial
Pues yo creo que tuvo una gran
incidencia en la literatura Porque con
el premio Nobel a García Márquez entró
dentro de las bibliotecas podríamos
decir serias del mundo toda esa magia
que había en sus libros que era una
magia muy asociada a la realidad pero yo
creo que el impacto y el efecto del
Nobel de García Márquez no quedó
solamente en la literatura sino que a
través del discurso que pronuncio en
estocolmo cuando recibió el premio tuvo
un impacto para la vida política y
social de la región Porque él fue quien
quien en ese discurso número Cuáles eran
las los retos los problemas pero también
las cualidades de todo el continente y
lo que lo unía y una identidad común no
Entonces yo creo que que García Márquez
No fue solamente un Nobel de literatura
sino algo mayor que trascendió a la
literatura